just to refresh your memory in case
you're like I can't remember if this is
where we started then we sort of had a
lot of it to be working in between yeah
we introduced T results we converted our
got it to a quadratic equation and then
this is what we got after using the
formula okay after this point we took
ten inverse and this is where things
started to get confusing okay so let me
see if I can explain a little bit
clearer now you remember that the first
thing you notice is out of the two
solutions within this new modified
domain right not 3.14 okay
this solutions fine okay but this
solution turns out to be a dud because
it's outside the domain right because
negative so the question that we were
getting sort of twisted and turned on
was well okay how do we get it into the
right domain all right so I've got two
ways for you to think about it I'll give
you both but I'm going to tell you which
one I prefer at the end for how do I get
in the right domain and a diamond door
but that's one right way to get in the
right away so here's option one okay the
first option is you can remember that
this is how this is a TN curve okay
so irrespective of what is in here okay
I mean if this was ten theta equals this
so you take 10 inverse so you had some
angle equal to this okay
now the period of regular old unchanged
10 is plank okay every plane you get a
new line so therefore the first thing
you can do is go from this line this one
to this one okay so what you're doing is
you're shifting the outside now this is
what we did a lot last time okay now if
you do that you'll get a number out
let's see here I think it's two point
six something six two three three
six three and then to get the actual
answer that we want you multiply by two
at that point which is how you get five
four point two six and so on okay now
this is this is what I'm going to
recommend okay because of the a decline
you always add PI every regardless of
what's going to be easier but the
question that region arts proposed
yesterday was what I said why PI because
if I'm eating that 10x on to 10 X 1/2
what it looks like is very similar to
the regular tankard but what is this
song what is it on to do what is that
half that coefficient it stretches it
out okay so if you remember I mean if I
did it the other way around
what this tells you that you get to lots
of the whole curve in the normal space
it doubles the it doubles the frequency
which is having the cube okay
but if I've got a front it's stretched
it out so instead of this being two pi
its rights no yeah yeah it's stretched
out its gesture I'm getting myself
killed
okay now so therefore the question was
why don't I add 2 pi because the period
of this thing is too high okay because
there's my complete cycle okay now
here's the thing which I'm this is what
I had trouble explaining yesterday and I
i saw the breakthrough you really are
actually adding 2 pi you are any 2 pi
it's just not that obvious ok so let me
make it more obvious if you think about
it from from that line right X on to
this okay now you're really adding 2 pi
because from here to here right sorry
actually from here to here you've
multiplied it right so adding PI here is
really adding 2 pi the full period right
by the end right at 6.28 what have you
okay so therefore you have this other
option instead of shifting it first okay
you can get here you can multiply
through
okay so I guess that would give you
minus 1.0 to do something like that
maybe two three I'm not sure how that
decimal goes
so having multiplying through by two now
you can apply a shift which as we've
noticed really should be 2pi okay which
is the real period of 10x one two okay
so it's gonna give you the same result
okay so which do you do first do you add
first and then multiply or do you
multiply first and then add I think it
makes more sense to add first okay
because it's always gonna be PI
regardless of how you've mucked around
with this period okay it could be Exxon
3x or 4x sort of whereas here okay you
have to think about okay what should I
add and how will it be different okay
which i think is more confusing so I I
prefer that an ADD and then multiply but
that's the reason why I'm not adding to
PI here because I really am adding 2 pi
it just only appears to be two pi later
on yes because it's excellent so if the
whole thing is on to as it were okay
that's that's what we get after using
these two results so hopefully there
clears it up a little bit there's my
first way there's my second way either
way is fine I do think it's important
that you should have write it like this
okay you don't just go from this line to
the next line with no break okay
because minus 0.02 2 is not the same as
minus 1 point into 2 plus 2 pi in this
case they are equivalent because of this
shift but these two lines aren't equal
that make sense
ok so again this is this is the way I
recommend any questions
so would you have to actually talk okay
I would probably say but maybe in here
because this is the method I prefer I'd
say but and then you cite the domain
right just like the Derby so because
it's outside of not 2 pi then it's up
there for you take this which is an
equivalent part up because trig
functions are periodic ok so just the
key is just to not have this flows on to
that directly because it does it it's
kind of a similar error to when you are
you've got some function okay and then
you differentiate it and then you are
thinking the question was like ask find
stationary points or something like that
so your next slide does this okay but
that's not true it's only true at
certain points right so there's a break
between these two lines which you're
sort of not actually talking about it's
sort of implied in your head and you
haven't said why okay so it's the same
kind of deal here all right